au siège de cette puissante association
indépendantiste pandémie oblige il n'y a
guère d'effervescence à quelques jours
du scrutin régional
ici on vit encore avec le souvenir du
référendum d'indépendance de 2017
mais la ferveur n'y est plus le camp
indépendantiste pen ar motiver ses
troupes
depuis des lourdes condamnations
prononcées à l'encontre des
organisateurs du référendum et de
l'incarcération des leaders politiques
responsables de la déclaration
d'indépendance alors ces élections c'est
peut-être l'opportunité d'un nouveau
souffle
c'était une année très compliquée à
cause de la pandémie mais aussi à cause
que la citation d'aimé part amélioré du
tout on a toujours les prisonniers
politiques sont toujours en prison
on a eu encore plus d'une reprise alliés
encore encore plus de monde qui est en
train d'aller en prison que de passer
par par les tribunaux donc même si
quelques parties espagnoles en train de
dire qu'il dit qu'il faut tourner la
page et regarder vers le futur
ils ont ils ont fait rien pour ça donc
l'état d'esprit d'un autisme maintenance
et il faut gagner encore une fois les
élections ils font encore une fois
démontré qu' il n'y a pas de solution
s'il ne passe pas par park au référendum
ou par l'indépendance si le débat
indépendantiste s'est un peu apaisée
dans la société catalane
il reste néanmoins la question centrale
de ces élections mais pour les opposants
au projet indépendantiste
elles sont une opportunité d'entamer un
nouveau site j'espère vraiment que ce
seront des élections de transition et
que le rôle qu'ils joueront les partis
constitutionnalistes sera essentielle
cela dépend d'eux et de leurs devoirs
envers les citoyens pour que ce soit
vraiment une étape de transition et
ainsi pouvoir mouiller tout ce que nous
avons vécu durant ces dernières années
des dernières années marquées par une
très forte participation cette année
l'abstention devrait être au rendez vous
en raison du contexte de la pandémie et
d'enjeux moins important que les années
précédentes
[Musique]
ces quinze dernières années la
participation est allé en augmentant et
son score le plus fort a été bien sûr en
c'est juste après le référendum
indépendantiste cette année à cause de
la pandémie mais aussi de la fatigue
sociale est une grande partie de la
population la participation et la
fluence électorale dae seront sans aucun
doute
dès dimanche soir la catalogne aura des
résultats mais il faudra encore attendre
les négociations de coalition pour
qu'elle ait un nouveau gouvernement